we're going to start off this hour from
Natasha in Oakland California hi Natasha
how are you I'm better than I deserve
days how about yourself
just the same how can I help well my
question today is regarding and being
debt-free and saving for retirement and
with the help of your plan my husband
and I had we're debt-free now we paid
off everything except for our house we
have a fully funded emergency fund so
we're on baby ship for saving that 15%
towards retirement and then and we do it
yeah it is it's a great feeling and we
do do a monthly budget together and
that's kind of where our disagreement
lies and we have a personal spending
line-item and my husband likes you have
a rather large personal spending item
and you know we haven't quite saved up
that 15% towards retirement so sorry all
women say save you don't save up 15%
towards retirements every month going
into right right right so your night are
not putting 15% in the retirement that's
correct
we right now I'm only putting in every
month about 4% of my retirement or my
income in here into the retirement fund
and we do have we did put a couple large
amounts into some separate IRA funds and
then I have a Roth 401k so how much do
you and your nest egg overall in your
household today and it's a little over
15,000 that's the total amount you guys
have saved for retirement between the
two of you that's correct okay and how
old are you 32 and my husband is 36 and
your household income is what and it's
about 87,000 before taxes okay and
you're debt-free except your home and
you have your emergency fund which
brings you to babysit for and say you
should be saving at that point then
about $13,000 a year between the two of
you in two good growth stock mutual
funds into your retirements a little
over $1,000 a month and your
not doing that that's right and there's
no spending account in the budget is how
much well this last month we had agreed
to like a hundred and twenty dollars
that's his that's his that your griping
about I can eighty seven thousand dollar
income it is it is um you know I just I
feel like you know he spends a lot of
undred and twenty dollars a month is a
lot well when you make eighty seven
thousand dollars a year you are a
serious tightwad girl well no I mean we
we budget out almost everything you know
we have a closing times we have like a
family fun fund so you know the personal
spending is kind of the things that like
if he wants to go get a coffee
he can do that you know or go to the
store and get a pack of gum yeah so you
know my question my question for you
today was you know we kind of have a
disagreement about it and we haven't
been and you're wrong he's right twenty
dollars is not too much okay it's my
that's very very very reasonable now I'm
worried about the rest of your budget
that out of eighty seven thousand
dollars you can't find a thousand
dollars a month to save towards
retirement and that's the part that you
two need to work on but it's not it's
not the fact that he's spending 120
bucks that's going on I mean you're just
being super nerd kiddo III think you
guys have done awesome you're making
great progress but I mean there are
spouses all over America wishing that
their spouse only had 120 dollars that
they overspent a month right listening
to this right now now that's that's
nothing
that's not bad at all I mean we're
talking about 30 40 bucks a week and
you're completely debt free you have
your emergency fund in place you're
saving towards retirement or you should
be that's not your problem and now you
lose the argument you shouldn't have
asked thanks Natasha hey you guys
Rachael Cruz here
you are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show
and did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better than the Dave Ramsey channel
don't tell them I said that I'm kidding
I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you